và khu vui trời dài chỉ và khách sản ở lần sân phát hiện gần 1,000 người đang bánh bản.
Ngày 20 tháng 2, hàng trong cán bộ chính sĩ kiểm tra khách sản và khu vui trời dài chỉ tại sáng khoảng ban thủ.
Lựa lượng chức năng phát hiện gần 1,000 người Việt Nam và nước ngoài, đang tham dài các trò lòng hộ, New New Phantan,
người trời dùng nhân dân tệ và tiên mặt để đổi chiếp đến bản.
Theo cương an, tu điểm đến bản trái phép này, nước món giữ hình thức tình dành trò chơi định từ có thường,
và gió một người Trung Quốc cầm đầu.
Tuy nhiên, giới dành nghĩa câu lộ vụ vui trời dài chỉ quốc tế,
nơi này đã lắc đặt bản đánh bản.
Hẹt thống camera, máy tính và thuyên người điều hành hoạt động lấy bản trái phép.
Đà, sư dụng, rất nhiều các tình thức tình bản.
Tình vì, các bạn nhá nước, các bạn sẽ có lấy bản.
Cái khoảng sinh bắt sự vi đã thu dữ một số lần, tên bản.
Tên, hoạt tệ và rất nhiều, đồng chiếp, dùng xử dụng,
Tại các bạn chứ?
Công man thu dữ hơn 200 phép, phề một chữ chíp, kương viên cần tảm tị đồng.
Khiếm chá cách sất,頃 lượng chức năng phát hiện thêm
gần tảm vui hai chữ chíp, quy đổi hơn 80-90, cùng nhiều tài liệu và tăng vật liên qua.
Công man tính đã khởi tốn v 완, khởi tủ s POB, về hành vì tổ chức nạn bản.
Và đánh bản.
Chẳng đó có mời tảm người Việt Nam.